I don't want to scare the children when
was the last time you saw someone
walking down the street with a mustache
on who didn't look like an absolute
creep Burt Reynolds that's pretty much
all I have actually as Burt Reynolds
they're all like pretty bold characters
I don't consider myself a bold character
I will look terrible with a mustache
I hope my girlfriend finds me someone
attractive gosh I don't know I hope I
don't look creepy I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna get teased by my friends though
I'm doing it in front of the baby
so I don't scare the baby so she knows
it's still me I do not know where the
mustache is supposed to start and end
you think this is a good look huh to
treat mustache baby I have a mustache
now it's it's very hard to see right now
did you just call her and look like a
little eyeliner heard there was a video
going on about this I'm like I'll just
see if I can join it so here I am
Frenchmen
Thanksgiving you get himself a straight
woman where's HR Chloe just walked up to
me and said oh you have a mustache and I
said yeah it's like what's that all
about I'm about to hop on an early
flight to Seattle there's mustache I
could be the pilot I've been out all day
and no one has really noticed or cared
or said anything it's like no one really
cares that I have them just a mustache
hold it's rainy if I could just feel
fair naked what my girlfriend likes it
but she also admits that she only likes
it cause it makes him laugh good white
and she just went through TSA and the
TSA agent looked at my ID looked at me
and said nice disguise I really like the
glasses mustache and big nose so I had a
mustache for almost a week now and no
one notices ever I've started telling
people some people just did not know who
I was when I said hi to them girlfriend
hated it my female co-workers hate it
women hate it they were all like you
should keep it no one commented on it my
friends didn't even notice there's hair
here people were just like yeah you get
to have a mustache when hair day
I faced out my dad and goes you look
like a tall I don't think it's fair for
girls to be able to come up and ridicule
my face but if a girl gets a certain
kind of haircut it's a huge faux pas to
comment on it I can't wait to get my
beard back I think I'm gonna keep it I
definitely would rather have had people
give me negative comments and be like
whoa you should not be wearing that then
no comments at all
I had my feelings hurt when people told
me they thought it looked gross you're
surprisingly vulnerable when you're in
between looks
it's not going off